so for the last year I redid some open
source components for react native one
of them is a rag native gifted chat
it's a chat UI that you can include in
your application in few minutes and it
will manage for you or the birds or the
the text input and some of those
features also I created a rack native
basketball game inspired by the Facebook
game in messenger and as you can see
it's pretty smooth thanks to the reg
native performance we'll create an
application we'll have two screens and
we'll do it in a live coding the first
Queen will have a form where we can put
a name then touch the next button to go
to the second screen second screen will
be a chat and yeah we'll be able to send
and receive some messages okay so the
first thing to do to get started with
reactive it's to install the iPhone and
Android SDK so in the documentation you
can find all the information you need
regarding this youyou have to know that
if you want to build for iPhone and iOS
you need a Mac you cannot do it on
Windows or Linux this is one restriction
so when you install everything you can
initialize your first project to do this
you have to type a command rack native
in it and a name of your project
okay yeah yeah thank you
so if you do this comment it will
generate for you a better plate of basic
application and let's see this t-shirt
so it will generate for you some files
like this this one first
it's NPM best project so you have a
package.json inside you will have the
dependencies of the project for example
by default it will be react and react
native and you have also here two
folders on Droid and iOS so the android
folder it's a real great project so you
can have access to the Android manifest
file for example and you can do some
fine-tuning here and in the iOS folder
you have an Xcode project so the same
way you can buy some people have access
to the info.plist and of course you have
some JavaScript code so here we have 2
to 5 and X iOS and index on droid so it
is on 3 points of the application I
always will use by default so as filed
and always on raid 5 so this is a
project that is generated after that to
run the simulator you have to run this
command it will start the simulator off
of iOS and by default this is a project
that you are welcome to write native and
on Android you have exactly some
behavior and
to run on trade you have to do run on
droid
okay let's go back to the index first
thing we will do is to create the first
screen I showed you before the first
screen will be this one so it will be
just a form we'll do it
so we create a new file here we'll put
it inside a folder slc components so we
will call it on the GS and here I will
start to create our first component to
do that you have to have both react
edges so you can import it because
inside the package file you have a
dependencies of react so you can import
it next step would be to import some
components from react native so we need
view in text I'll show you what can we
go with it and next up will be to create
a component to do that you have to
create a class and will be called on
home and it should extend from react
component to make it a component I
thought that you need to create a render
method and inside this method you will
say what you want to display on the
screen so we create an return function
and inside will write write some GS code
j6 code it looks like HTML but it's not
it's JavaScript but using some types of
es6 called ga6
and here we'll write arrow home so it's
not a and then you need to export this
class to make it impossible
so here we have our first component I
will copy it and I will create a new
file we'll call it this time
shut the GS it will be the second screen
and I will just rename the name of the
class here and flowchart ladies so for
now we have two files index is an index
on droid what we want its to have only
one file to to share the code between
the two platforms so we remove
everything here and also on Android and
then we will do from scratch together so
in index iOS for example we will first
thing to do is to import approach 3 from
react native it will be useful to tell
to relative what is the main component
so the main component will be read
related to the routine to do that we
need to call the restock component from
app forestry first parameter is the name
of the application we called it chat app
and then it receive a function a
function and this function should return
a component so we go it up and this up
component I imported and will create
just after that so here in this up fired
I didn't create yet I would create it
and I will share it between iOS and
Android so here I use the registry to
direct achieve what is the root
component the first one to to display
and we do it like this so in es6 we have
new syntax here instead of writing the
function like this you can use
the fataroo like this and to return
something so here there is an implicit
return in this function so it makes our
code a bit shorter save this file I will
copy it in Android and then I will
create my app the GS file here and in
this file we will manage the navigation
between the pages so we need to import
react from react and we import also so
the two components we created the first
one was home from it's located in
components folder we import also chat
from same folder and we need something
to manage the routing so we will use an
open source one called react native root
of routes
so inside we need from this open source
library Rooter and sin to be able to
import it first we need to enter it
science it's not yet in the dependencies
to type to edit in your project you have
to so this is a relative project here
you have to do NPM install the name of
the package and save to add it to the
package that is on fire
we do it Jenny could be in sir why did
censoring we can still continue to to
work on the application here will create
so this app component it will extend
from a react component to make it a
component inside we have a random method
to display something on the screen and
here we'll have so the router have also
a wood scene inside we will have to send
oh man chat will use and add title so
here this is the name of the route will
access using this value component is
what to what component to use and title
will be in the navigation bar it will be
displayed at the top we do the same for
the chat the chat screen will have a
different title and a different
component and then we are to export the
app component we can save this and we'll
try
so so it was loading its because when
you run the rag native project so first
it starts the emulator and also it
starts what we call as a packager here
automatically this package is that kind
of web pack and is all is to bundle all
your GS file of your project into one
file and serve it to the application
it's a kind of web server if you want
for example if i refresh my app you see
that the server is answering with the
content and this is only for development
when you build for release you don't
have anymore the need of the package so
here we have our first component but we
cannot see the content we wrote hello
home it is not displayed because it's
behind the navigation bar so we have to
add here as a root scene a padding top
so you will see that look like CSS and
using the style prop we can set a value
I will refresh and now I can see the my
my content what I want to show you now
is for example in Android I will open it
and I will refresh the position will not
be the same because the navigation bar
here it's smaller than the iOS one so
here there is a margin so I will show
you how to make a condition if you want
to customize the Android or iPhone so to
do that you have to import from react
native platform component and with this
you can set the condition if platform OS
equals iOS then you will use the value
64 or font-weight for example 54 can
save and refresh which will be a bit
different so it's better now so we can
still make conditions you know you know
application if we want something very
specific the next step here will be to
add the form to the first page we would
remove the arrow home here we don't need
and the first thing was you can see we
are enter your name labelled here then
we have a text input and then we have a
button so it will be entire name first
here we save and see how it's displayed
so we will add some styling here to do
that first you need to import from react
native stash it and it will allow you to
to create some styling so we can declare
a variable style in unused stat sheet
create and inside you can put your your
start so this first one will be title it
will be will add margin top 20 margin
left 20 and it's from size 20 and to use
it you will have to pass it as a prop to
the text component like this right and
just to pass a viable style title you
can save and we load and you see that
the style is applied here so it's like
CSS but it's not exactly CSS so you have
to check the documentation to see what
properties here you can use so now we
see something very useful
it's the odd reloading so by pressing
command D you can enable the red native
development menu and you have access to
enable ultra loading here and with this
feature you can change your component
save the file and automatically it will
be refreshed and you can walk faster
alright this next step is to add the
text input will add a star will you call
it name input will have a placeholder to
be if I don't well so we create this new
style yeah name input we want 840 we'll
add a border it's a bother with to water
color black and margin 20 and we'll see
how it is displayed text input is not
defined
why because I didn't import it here you
can only use the component you import
this is not the case if you do some
react for web you in web you can already
use all the HTML tag like div and so on
in reg native this is the difference you
have to import first what you want to
use and here you cannot use a HTML tag
it's really you need to import only the
one from relative or you have to create
your own so we have our text input you
know we just add padding the next step
will be to add a button will add
touchable opacity its component from the
reg native rubber right here
we need first to import it inside we
have to add the text and the text button
will be just next next string with 7c so
we have now this button to know what you
can import here you have to check the
documentation react native on the left
you have the list of what you can use
for now we just use view the text and
the touchable opacity so touchable
opacity basically it's a view with the
ability to listen to the touch events so
sorry I will add some styling to the
touchable opacity and text so the text
will use a new style we'll call it
button text for example we add this new
style and we'll just set the position
with the left and the font size we have
our button next step will be to go to
the next screen
to do that use the touchable opacity you
can pass an unprecedent
here so you pass to it a function which
you can use a fat our keyword the fatter
okay what is used for air because you
can keep the scope of the container so
if you do this here this is really the
class so this is useful to to use a
photograph' 212 access to the cup of the
class so here the goal will be to
navigate to the second screen and to
pass it the name
the name will be stored in the state
this is a feature of react so the text
input when you will type a character
will store each character to make it
accessible when we want so to do that we
need to set a state party vote it will
be a name with an empty string and the
text input can will update this name to
do that we need to create an option here
change text so it's a prop you have to
use these contacts and change text you
pass it a function this function will
receive a text it will be the text typed
by the user and we will use this text to
update the name state so we need to use
this set state in this method we say
that we want to change the name to the
text value and we need to use this value
using the value prop to the text input
so here at the unpress for now we just
adapt to see if we can retrieve properly
this string let's save
all right row type next and we can
display the we have access to the name I
will show you now a bit of debugging you
can use the console log here and user D
state name and then you have to enable
using the development menu the debug GS
remotely feature then it will should
open automatically a tab in your browser
it works only for Chrome and here in the
console you have the reg native logs I
will just press ENTER and so we first
need to type something and then it
displayed here so you can develop like
this also you have the possibility to
add a breakpoint here using the debugger
keyboard and when you do that it will
stop the code at the step a refresh and
here automatically just there is a break
point so it can be useful for debugging
refresh so we will navigate to the
second screen to do that we need to
first to import a component from our
water so from pregnancy photo flux will
import action
this action will be used here to
navigate to the second screen so it will
be chat extended shot because the route
the name is a key we use voice chat
that's why so here we'll pass the name
and we'll get the name from the state
ladies now we can go to our chat
component and here we will receive the
name - to have access to the name you
need to use the dis props name it's
located all the props are located inside
the disk dot props so we'll try we'll
type in shown here so the name is
retrieved here and displayed so here my
ears Clint is telling me that name is
missing in props validation it's because
it's a good practice to set a default
value for name in case you you don't
have it so to do that you need to do
chat key for props and here you can set
all your value so by default you can say
joelandfi sample also you can set a prop
types
it means that you accept only value with
this type so here we want only string so
we need to use react prop types that
string sorry
[Music]
yeah yeah there is a mistake here oh
yeah thank you
you're right thanks right so here should
work so it's a good practice we can set
the hell or the props you receive next
step will be to implement the chat so
we'll use a component I created
it's called gifted chat it's in two
lines
sorry you can add a chat UI it looks
like this but you can customize you can
change the color or you can change a lot
of things and the only things you will
have to do for us it's to install it so
we'll go back to the terminal
and we will type this command npm
install and it will add this component
into our project and then we have to use
to do like this example so this
component will copy this and then i will
pass here so to receive messages props
here will have a list of messages to
display and then send method so what to
do when we will send the message and the
identification of the user well here
what is interesting is that how easily
it is to implement and reuse a component
so you can create component for what you
want and just by using different props
you can use the same conference in
different projects so just take messages
here we'll create like this
by default it will be an empty error
and here we don't need any more UN text
you can remove so we need to import this
if Deadshot continent from this library
so you can just check the package that
reason yeah
when we do implement star save they are
added here so that's why we can import
them so we have our component second
props it's a non set content method so
here you receive the message to send and
you can send it to your back-end
I think we are good so now the next step
will be to add some back-end code so I
already prepared some code so I will
check I will change my own branch
we check out another branch but first I
will stop the package or to be sure
there is no conflict and then I will
start it again so what I did I just open
it a different branch and on this branch
is the same code but I added some some
codes to
to show you first how to implement a
back-end so a new file in the project is
this one the backend basically it's just
a firebase back in with some methods
here I just initialize the connection I
have a method here locked edges to get
the messages from the backend and I have
a send message method here and finally I
close
Todd to close the connection with
firebase and I will use this method in
the chat so let's go back to the chat
comprehend and here so first we need to
import this back-end file and so for the
sending I added I have added my method
here I retrieve the ID of the user and
the name so here we have new methods we
have component will mount hospital I did
yeah what is it
all react components have a life cycle
it means that before the rendering there
with component will mount cold and
inside this method you can do some
operations then after the rounder you
have the component did mount so here I
decided to wrote the messages from the
server at this moment to first to
display an empty chat and then to add
the messages just after the first
rounder and then we have a method
component with a note
it's called when you when you cross the
chat the for example if you go back to
the home page this component will amount
will be lunch and I think we can try if
it's walking so this is iOS this is
Android refresh on the Left we'll set
the name Android and alright I will set
I phone and we'll try to chat and it
will be the the last step of the
application so here we'll call on droid
to see if it works and the message is
received
[Applause]